I guess quick Chinese lesson just for
fun this is a character for peace
alright so that is yeah ok so that is
pronounced this way second tone ping and
ok
this means level or even so if you had
say ping Jun if you had pink gin gin is
would be this character a little sloppy
but you got the idea
kidding that would be average okay I
like the average the mean okay so ping
ping is peace and just to show you how
this character is constructed some
people will love this some people won't
but this is a roof this radical on the
top and this is a woman underneath it's
a woman under a roof in a home means
peace or peaceful and you can construct
other characters really easily using
this second one just to give you an idea
so you might have for instance that's
boom it's a little sloppy but you get
the idea
boom which means public boom and it
means so Public Safety Public Security
that's also kind of a police officer
alright so and then you could have gone
un-boom UN's Park alright so you got a
public peace you have sort of even peace
means at peace no cause for worry etc
hope that is interesting to some of you
have a beautiful day